these guys use brute force
they're strong they're too strong then
they might be a part of the big three
what big threat
androids aliens and wizards that's not a
thing that's definitely
no it's not
there are no wizards dr strange is a
sorcerer a sorcerer is a wizard without
a hat
a regional series streaming march 19th
exclusively on disney plus
our country is vulnerable
we need new heroes
let's get to work
we're not a team nope
or partners
co-workers
we look damn good
streaming march 19th exclusively on
disney plus
the world's upside down right now
where do we start
superheroes that cannot be allowed
people to exist they need a cat
damn right
original series streaming march 19th
exclusively on disney plus
[Music]
the legacy of that shield is
complicated
[Music]
the world
it's upside down
people need something to get behind
[Music]
i need the symbol
so what's our plan
so no plan
great
[Music]
what's going on in that cyborg brain of
yours you don't want to know
oh yeah i can see it working gear's
turning
oh they're malfunctioning they're on
fire
you